[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans votre
émission 7,8 débat après les nombreuses
polémiques sur le coup l'utilité de
certaines lignes du grand paris express
le premier ministre à edouard philippe a
développé ce matin le nouveau calendrier
des chantiers
si l'ensemble des lignes de métro sont
maintenus sans modification du tracé ou
de suppression de gare c'est au prix de
quelques sacrifices
le montant global des travaux doit être
réduit et la livraison de certaines
lignes reporter ce qui impacte le
premier tronçon de la ligne 18 entre
orly et saclay qui sera tordait retarder
de deux à trois ans quelles seront les
conséquences de ce report est faut-il
encore croire à cette nouvelle annonce
pour débattre de ces questions
j'accueille autour de moi jean michel
fourgous président de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines
didier baichère député de la république
en marge des yvelines daniel denis
coordinateur des mères haut et
associations opposés à ce projet et
enfin hors smith coordinateur du
collectif colosse un groupe de réflexion
sur l'aménagement urbain saclay saint
quentin en yvelines
bonsoir à vous tous et merci d'avoir
participé à cette émission alors le
tronçon orly saclay a été tout d'abord
prévu pour 2024 aujourd'hui le premier
ministre a annoncé qui sera au plus tard
délivré en 2027
la ministre des transports a dit que ce
projet est en fait n'était pas tout à
fait une priorité qui n'était recaler
monsieur le député ce que votre
gouvernement considère que le
développement de saclay n'est pas une
priorité une fine est ce que pour vous
c'est un camouflet lors bonsoir merci
pour l'invitation
moi j'étais à cette réunion par contre
je n'ai pas entendu la ministre dire que
ça n'était pas une priorité
donc je au contraire et l'intérêt de
juger un chantier recalés manger j'ai
entendu très précisément qu'il y avait
trois objectifs pour le grand paris
express et que dans le premier objectif
qui était cité c'était le rayonnement
économique et elle a pris l'exemple du
plateau de saclay donc non je pense
qu'il ya une vraie priorité
après il ya un moment donné en fait dans
ce projet dans l'ampleur les 200 km de
métro souterrain qu'on devra réaliser en
ile de france
il ya une nécessité d'un discours de
vérité et si on parle de recalage c'est
parce que probablement depuis dix ans on
se raconte des histoires qui font qu'on
aboutit nulle part et aujourd'hui il
faut décider parce que les travaux
commencent en le chantier du grand paris
express a commencé et les travaux pour
la ligne 18 pour ce qui nous concerne
nous devons aussi commencer dès 2018
voici donc c'était important d'avoir une
décision et c'est quand même une
reculade après l'annulation de
l'exposition universelle maintenant on
apprend ce lundi 18 sera une fille ni
retardée alors que vous et votre voisin
monsieur focus vous avez quand même
signé une lettre ouverte pour demander
justement le maintien de la ligne de
mineurs pour que la nuit soit ouverte en
dépit de 24 ans s'est battu moi je
voudrais juste qu'on fasse un retour
arrière au mois de septembre
si vous vous souvenez au mois de
septembre en fait c'est le tronçon
saclay versailles donc qui passe par
saint quentin était potentiellement en
train de disparaître et l'ajout annoncé
que sa dette à bouger ce sera les
ballons j'ai je me souviens très bien de
ce déplacement d'elisabeth bornes sur le
plateau de saclay chez bd comme à qui
nous avons fait dire très précisément à
ce moment là et c'est un long travail de
préparation qui a mené à cette décision
que la ligne 18 irait jusqu'à son terme
d'accord est ce que vous partagez cette
opinion quand une fille née tout va bien
peu importe ce report nous mais il faut
être plus il faut parler du fond c'est
la forme la communication l'éclat val
d'oise présente sur place par l'ong
comme on dit en france qu'elle est calé
le quel est le contenu quoi
on parle d'un projet un modèle
d'hypercroissance dont la france a
besoin je l'aï fait par une hyper
croissance de 3% vous pourrez pas payer
vos retraites ou de ces personnes lui
dit enfin bon vous pourrez pas payer vos
fonctionnaires ni nil retraite mais ça
c'est grave quand on vous dit 25000 ya
un projet bon ensuite on vous dit 38
qu'est ce que c'est que les quidams et
kiki qui pilote les prévisions déjà il
ya un problème de sérieux quand même
deuxièmement quand on dit en
communication un coup on dit on sait que
c'est 2024 on a passé un accord pour
avoir les jeux olympiques pour aussi à
avoir ce set 6-2 en 2024 ainsi que les
engagements qu'on a pris avec les
entreprises de paris saclay avec les
laboratoires avec les grandes écoles
enfin qu'est ce que ça veut dire de
remettre des délais comme ça soit la
france est en faillite et puis bon faut
le dire et puis on va on va trouver les
bonnes solutions il faut pas dire autre
chose à des acteurs locaux comme nous
qui prenons des engagements on est
sérieux on vient de l'entreprise on
trouve les sérieuses pour sa part ces
variations très peu de budget ni de
délai comme ça vous allez c'est réagir
les personnes qui sont posées cette
ligne vaut ce que pour vous sa victoire
en son nom dont certains du tonneau ces
termes que ça se pose je crois que le
problème est très sérieux je suis assez
d'accord avec la façon où vous le posez
c'est à dire que il ya une épreuve de
vérité parce qu'il est évident que c'est
un gouvernement actuel qui est qui qui a
apporté le passif de cette différence
d'évaluation entre les 19 milliards et
les 38 vous donner c'est la société du
grand paris qui a explicitement fléché
c'est une somme qu'on savait faux ce
pour simplement rendre davantage
acceptable l'idée de faire ce vieux
projet de monsieur christian blanc ça
date de 2006 cette affaire donc de ce
point de vue le
le l'erreur initiale en quelque sorte ça
a été des évaluations premières
notamment moment réunion s'en est saisi
au moment de l' enquête d'utilité
publique où on a dit mais les
évaluations ne sont pas fondées or on en
a fait un recours en conseil d'état donc
entre parenthèses faudra peut-être
attendre éventuellement la réponse du
conseil d'état avant de commencer les
travaux sinon ça pourrait mal filmé en
virilité
donc on a déposé un recours pour quoi
pour plusieurs raisons la question a été
évoquée il ya eu il ya quelque chose qui
ne fonctionne pas depuis le début c'est
rien mensonge effectifs au montant de
cette affaire nous l'a dit on a suggéré
qu'il y avait des montants qui était
inexacte on en a fait un élément du
recours et qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on
lit le rapport de la cour des comptes il
ya un mois
ainsi 140 pages extrêmement instructif
dans lequel on a tout à fait la
confirmation de notre approche c'est à
dire que le modèle économique initiale a
été hachée en fait pour tromper
l'opinion publique pour lui dire on va
le faire parce qu'on peut le faire
est ce que vous partagez notre pouvoir
pour vous cet allongement ça vous permet
de mieux structurer justement les
personnes qui sont contre ce projet ce
que vous gagnez du temps allongement en
soit il n'est pas significatif sauf que
maintenant il va falloir trouver
d'autres solutions
enfin il devient plus urgente encore de
trouver d'autres solutions que celles la
ligne 18 qui n'est pas une solution
il n'est pas pertinente comme solution
on a démontré récemment lors des assises
de la mobilité que la ligne 18 collecte
des bassins d'emploi qui n'ont rien à
voir entre eux et que son tracé est
perpendiculaire
partout vous faut ce qui par
perpendiculaires aux principaux flow
flux de déplacements en particulier dans
le secteur de saclay les flux de
déplacement sont nord-sud sont pas est
ouest répondre je vais prendre un
exemple très concret pour qu'on sache de
pompe à lundi lundi cette semaine
j'étais sur le plateau de saclay sur le
campus de paris tech
pour commencer à travailler sur sur des
sujets d'analystes de big data avec une
école de prestigieuses qui est localisée
la série en fait qui inquiète localiser
là où j'étais l'après-midi avec rte est
née disent qu'ils travaillent sur
l'énergie des transports de notre
énergie
ces deux discussions au même moment sur
des territoires qui peuvent sembler très
éloignées quand vous avez pas de
transport pour faire le lien entre les
deux font que ces deux acteurs
extrêmement important de l'économie ne
se parlent pas naturellement or est né
dit souhaiter aujourd'hui a besoin de la
puissance de la big data de l'analyse
des données pour pouvoir faire des
économies d'énergie et remplir les
décisions que nous avons prises en
matière de réduction énergétique avec la
ligne 18
le flot des étudiants et des entreprises
se trouvera extrêmement simplifiée entre
le plateau entre le plateau de saclay
afrique et 57 monsieur donc j'ai encore
une fois vous savez quand l' enquête a
été ouverte ont parlé de 100 mille
passagers
la dernière étude que saint quentin en
yvelines a fait en parle ou d'aller
jusqu'à 200 milles vous savez plus le
temps va avancer c'est lui le temps
avance et fait parler les gens qui vont
au ceva tous les jours et qui a mis un
set à rien à voir avec 50,1 les chiens
sèchement je vous assure je pense que
parler aux étudiants qui vont à denfert
rochereau et qui doivent aller à
l'université de paris sud est qui habite
saint quentin en yvelines demandez-leur
la galère qu'ils ont tous les jours oui
mais devant développés ils ont développé
des relations puissante entre nos
entreprises à saint quentin en yvelines
sur le futur plateau de satory wii et sa
clé c'est sûr ça l'avait déplacée sur
l'avenir dont nous avons besoin vont pas
faire la pendule longueur de journée et
communique par internet évidemment
décisions notamment nous concentrer sur
ça aujourd'hui
si vous faites mais on va se concentrer
notamment sur aujourd'hui parce que tu
sais plus où si non c'est très bien mais
la ministre a fait une nouvelle annonce
notamment sur le renforcement du réseau
de bus monsieur fourgous est-ce que vous
c'était quelque chose que vous attendiez
notamment de sa solution avoir davantage
de bus entre massy et
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ajouté
une ligne supplémentaire parallèle à une
route
enfin il faut voir ce qu'il faut voir ce
que ça veut dire sortir sa fin c'est
pareil on a on est une classe parlant
dans ce pays mais j'accuse ni la gauche
et la droite c'est une espèce délit qui
qui qui au fait aujourd'hui travailler
sans concertation avec les élus jouent
dit nous on est sur le terrain donc on
voit ce qui est possible ce qui va lui
aussi annoncé hier matin à 30 ans mais
non mais attention est ce que c est ce
que c'est réalisable n'ont de toute
façon vous avez et pour reprendre ce que
dit nono deux messieurs face classé c on
a l'impression que vous n'êtes pas
conscient des problèmes que l'on à
résoudre alors j'ai pas que son niveau
d'activité
mais paris saclay cc vous êtes contre
paris saclay cela si vous êtes contre le
développement contre de donner les
moyens de transport les moyens
universitaires les grandes écoles pour
faire venir les entreprises les
meilleurs les plus meilleurs
laboratoires vous dit donnons les
chiffres non il n'y a pas vraiment
besoin d'une ligne de transport
mais vous savez tous les élus en vous
écoutant ils vont bloquer tous les
projets de développement de cette zone
là si c'est ce que vous voulez mais vous
vous êtes représentatif là en dix ans
afin d'aider les gens quand les gens
contre leur finance leurs retraites qui
n'est pas financé ils sont au courant de
ce que vous dites là ce qu'on plus
d'employés ce million et demi de
personnes du coup quand vous venez de
voter enfin vous devez aussi rêver de
chasser les réquisitions à témoigner
vous venez de votre terre déficit de 84
milliards mais est ce que vous réalisez
non vous êtes l'ayant mais non nous on
n'a pas besoin la croissance ou sur ceux
du s'était plus montré le chiffre
méthodes et b non mais sérieux là c'est
c'est important c'est important de faire
de réussir ce projet qui devrait être un
modèle français pour nous pour nos
chercheurs pour l'excellence de nos
chercheurs de nos laboratoires de nausée
quand vous avez le plus beau de l'année
de concentration estudiantine en haut
valais se répondent déjà compris votre
attachement ce projet-là effet réussir
ce dernier et messieurs les 3% de
croissance dont vous parlez et c'est
comme du 4%
christian blanc c'est totalement hors de
portée on est dans une
on est aujourd'hui dans les trente
douloureuse monsieur n'est pas dans les
trente glorieuses
donc on va vous voyez votre retrait du
ciel si on dit ça
la dimension académique il a entièrement
raison nous sommes en train de
travailler sur la fusion de trois
universités sur le plateau de saclay
dont celle de saint quentin en yvelines
qu'est ce qui va se passer si on ne peut
pas transporter correctement des
étudiants à travers cette ville
étudiante cccc enfin pour 50 individus
fille c'est la fin d'une dimension
c'est la fin d'une dimension académique
sérieuse sérieuse oui on a une
université aujourd'hui ceux qui
traversent le plateau ils sont très très
peu nombreux et un bus était en moyenne
un support notamment sur les
finalement c'est tout à fait contre le
développement notamment universitaires
je suppose internet ces valeurs se
permet trop écouté mais d'abord je
souhaite tout parle tranquillement de
tout ça parce que c'est pas on n'est pas
dans une ford empoigne on est dans un
projet qui maintenant à une douzaine
d'années
quel projet qui a été lancé par
christian blanc qui est un projet qui
est très claire et qui consiste à
urbaniser l'ensemble de la région dans
saint comme il le dit c'est à dire de
faire un grand paris qui va être donc
dans l'esprit de ses promoteurs comme
quelque chose qui doit être densifié
alors au départ le projet c'était d'être
150000 habitants sont le plateau de
saclay et vous en souvenir c'est au
moment de lober de de la doyenne d'un de
ce projet d'intérêt national
ensuite il ya eu des doutes je veux
pendant ce temps là on montre des images
du plateau et de son agriculture
il ya eu déjà eu des réactions qui
consistait à dire mais ce plateau de
saclay a passé les plus belles terres
agricoles d'europe
du point de vue du rendement et il faut
pas faux pas le saccage et en urbanisant
dans la totalité or petit à petit un
certain nombre d'acteurs et notamment
tous ces maires qui sont dans les
vallées et qui dispose du plateau de
saclay à leur guise en quelque sorte
comme d'un terrain d'expansion qui vise
en fait à donc urbanisées donc je crois
que c'est ça la grande question avant de
reprendre point par point des questions
plus sectorielles qui ont toutes un
intérêt évident le développement de
l'université et le rapport à la
recherche et le rapport à l'industrie ça
c'est des vrais enjeux je pense qu'on
pourrait en parler de façon tout à fait
convaincante entre nous même si on n'est
pas d'accord
l'enjeu de l'agriculture ne faut pas
oublier quand même que ça existe et que
le lan clave la de la zone dite
naturelle qui est de 2300 hectares très
vite
en fait vous revenez en attendant sans
problème est de là que dieu que d'une je
ris tout ce qui fait que ça la question
du plateau de saclay n'est pas une
question qu'on peut réduire à un train
électrique que des gens attendent parce
qu'ils ont écrit au père noël pour avoir
cette bo petit train qui va sillonner la
campagne même si six à douze mètres je
suis pas sûr que les personnes qui sont
confrontés tous les jours
moi je vous ai je l'utilisé les
transports en commun avant de déplacer
un donc je suis arrivé en retard à la
réunion du premier ministre ce matin
encore parce que j'utilisais transports
en commun toujours donc je sais ce que
c'est très bien je ne crois pas qu'on
peut décrire des choses comme ça déjà
les terrains agricoles y en a une grande
partie sur le plateau qui ont été
sanctuarisés
tous ces débats ils ont eu lieu j'ai vu
moi je suis ravie enfin on est tous
passionnés par ce projet je suis ravi
qu'il ait lieu sauf qu'à un moment donné
on fait ce grand métro moi j'habitais
disant avoir bretonneux donc je sais
qu'on fera jamais du souterrain voisins
le bretonneux puisque la maison que
j'avais à bosser un bretonnant elle
était sur pilotis parce que c'est des
anciens marécages et c'est tout le monde
le savait tous les gens qui habitent là
le savent on peut on peut tout ça ça
déjà été étudiées donc il ya un moment
donné c'est soit ces souterrains
soit c est rien et je crois que les
arbitrages des enquêtes publiques elles
ont été faites on doit avancer 12 en mai
rendez vous compte ça c'est extrêmement
finalement arriver à un projet qui est
quasiment le même
le à l'origine cantine et répliquées
notamment aujourd'hui sur le présent
justement ça fait déjà deux ans que ça
fait déjà pratiquement dix ans que ça
traîne ça va encore traîner des années
supplémentaires comment on fait pour
améliorer aujourd'hui le quotidien par
rapport à ce grand projet assure foreuse
mais déjà on remet les élus autour de la
table et j'irai quelque chose s'appelle
la démocratie
messieurs on peut être en désaccord
c'est la règle est mort il ya une crise
il doit trancher et puis on doit la
respecter
d'accord il ya des problèmes graves dans
ce pays à régler les opportunités
extraordinaires qui ont été lancés de
paris saclay ce soit la silicon valley à
la française de demain
ce soit c'est bien ça vous fasse et que
ces beaux mots clés de sabre ça dure et
sans saveur
silicon valley s'est pas fait c'est
mignon pour moi les bonnes universités
non mais si jamais vous avez le droit
d'être contre tout même contre la
croissance que vous mettez tout la
croissance qui est un monde messieurs
ben voyons
ben voyons on peut faire aussi de la
croissance zéro mais est ce que les
français safran ça veut dire sérieux sur
son engagement il s'agit de donner des
chiffres le plus vite possible
des chiffres bien vérifier voilà et de
mettre les élus autour de la table les
élus peuvent aussi apporter une
contribution une contribution bien sûr
d'ordre de 2 en termes de solutions et
ou même en termes techniques ou même
économique mais on ne peut pas rester
comme ça dans un débat où on a
l'impression que on est un sincère avec
nous que l'on nous fait pas participé et
qu'on nous pour sortir de ce problème
l'état dit y a qu'à dire 2030 d'abord la
majorité ne sera pas forcément rayures
qu'est ce que ça veut dire qu'est ce que
ça veut dire démocratiquement de dire
cela mais je dirais la même chose si
c'était monsieur fillon c'est pas parce
qu'il faut distinguer ce qui est du rôle
de l'état est ce qui va être le rôle de
la région et jeudi au passage de j'ai
entendu valérie pécresse ce matin dire
clairement qu'elles remettent les élus
autour de la table pour la partie qui va
concerner ile-de-france mobilité en ce
que quand on parle de d'ici à 2020
mettre un bus en site propre entre
saclay et saint quentin en yvelines
c'est pas forcément lumière des
différentes villes qui vont décider
c'est quelque chose qui va se faire avec
avec la puissance de la région ils vont
sûrement d'autres d'autres acteurs qui
se mettront autour de la table le l'état
a pris l'engagement clair ferme et
définitif d'engager les budgets à
hauteur de 35 à 38 milliards pour
réaliser l'intégralité du grand paris
express
selon un calendrier qui a été définie ce
matin alors après skyrie price qui
restera pas c'est moi il ya quelque
chose qui m'a frappé un ce matin pendant
la démonstration il ya aujourd'hui en
france 4 tunnelier qui travaillent en a
23 ans d'europe
il y en aura 21 qui travailleront pour
le grand paris express donc imaginer le
chantier pharaonique que nous sommes en
train de mettre sur la table c'est c'est
extraordinaire ce qui va se passer
donc oui il ya des aléas je pense qu'on
les a tous en tête maintenant le budget
il est sur la table il ya aussi une
mission qui est confiée
gilles carez qui a quand même été
longtemps président de la commission
finances à l'assemblée nationale qui est
respecté et qui va regarder comment
optimiser ce budget par exemple vous
n'êtes pas seulement opposés à son
projet là vous proposait notamment
d'autres alternatives depuis longtemps
et depuis longtemps et il faut bien le
dire on commence simplement a été
écoutée sur ce plan maintenant il faut
le préciser vous auriez d ailleurs puis
venir vous étiez invité plusieurs de vos
collègues sont venus monsieur barreaux
il venu ils sont venus à des assises
pendant organisé il y avait 500
personnes y avait des élus et il y avait
des techniciens il y avait des
urbanistes etc
et il y avait des spécialistes des
transports en particulier des transports
dont on pense qu'ils sont utiles dès
maintenant et non pas dans seulement
dans dix ans puisque c'est le problème
qui est posé et ça les a lus aurait pu
quand même le savoir il ya cinq ou six
ans que même si je lève 2024 eh bien on
serait en retard par rapport aux besoins
qui sont aujourd'hui donc il ya des
différentes propositions alternatives
qui existent des autobus je vois que
tout le monde en rigole d'envoi le
rendez compte la silicon valley que des
autobus et qu'ils aillent à la silicon
valley voit reconnaître sa sauce où il
ya des autobus le canada il ya les
autres un gardien qui vient du j ai
passé trois ans donc séparé des autobus
et par les véhicules avec le wifi à
l'intérieur mais on parle de de services
à haute valeur ajoutée
jusqu'au 10 octobre us il ya des
discussions nombreuses qui ont été
faites sur les téléphériques parce que
c'est le sait la nécessité du trafic
nord-sud qui n'est pas du tout qui n'est
pas du tout les services qui fait que
les embouteillages sont causés par 7,7
congruence entre un gros trafic nord-sud
et un trafic est ouest qui vient sur le
plateau
et là on a le gros du problème puisque
80 % des gens qui viennent au boulot ils
viennent de l'essonne ou du nord diw sa
guérison du nord sud
donc la ligne 18 si on enlève toute
polémique
de principe je dirais deux hommes elle
n'a pas sa pertinence par rapport à ce
problème précis par contre il ya de
l'urgence parce que les gens maintenant
ils sont là et donc effectivement
foulées trop fonder servir alors là il
est de fait que madame pécresse qui
d'ailleurs était pour un certain nombre
d'aménagements du projet de lim 18
initialement a fait voter des voeux au
conseil régional au moment de l' enquête
publique et les poursuit maintenant pour
que y est véritablement des des
alternatives qui sont apportées
notamment les p&t les téléphériques
c'est ça qui sont dans les urgences
et si les élus veulent rendre service au
projet c'est pas de dire lille 18 une 18
en trépignant mais c'est de favoriser
les transports qui vont amener les gens
là où ils sont nés ses sens entièrement
sur la même ligne et comme j'ai dit le
trafic entre entre pôles d'activité et
compte pour 3 % du trafic total donc
c'est totalement inutile de s'acharner
sur des solutions qui ne lanceront pas
la solution que notre on a besoin c'est
de faire venir les gens depuis les rer
qui existe qui passe juste à côté du
plateau voulu est reversé de l'autre
côté pour vieux pour faire des
rabattements entre les rues air et le
plateau et ça ça peut se faire avec des
téléphériques ou avec d'autres moyens
que nous sommes en train de promouvoir
un qu'ils ont beaucoup plus puissant et
qui qui sont là bien bien avant la ligne
18 bien avant les dix ans au moins ça va
prendre au moins dix ans voire plus
parce que on parle aujourd'hui de 2027
mais évidemment il va y avoir des
retards supplémentaires si ça ce n'est
jamais que sur le papier tout ça c'est
comme un maudit parce qu'il ya quand
même un problème sur ce tracé parce qu'
elle ne va pas faire la connexion avec
eux le 59e nagarhar c'est donc est-ce
que ça c'est audible d'entendre
notamment de davantage développer les
aux lignes de transport doux tout
simplement ensemble 59 l'insee le poumon
économique de paris saclay 50 ans est le
deuxième pib par habitant
après paris là aussi du projet
universitaire sur dix mille étudiants
c'est lié à cette proximité avec le
monde de l'entreprise où il ya un talent
extraordinaire en plus le bon donc si
vous si vous cassez sa-7 ce lien entre
ces soixante dix mille étudiants et les
meilleurs entreposés dans les meilleures
entreprises françaises qui sont bons
vous vous cassez l'ensemble du projet or
ce projet c'est un modèle 7 1 me alors
vous allez droit de penser différemment
mais c'est un modèle pour pour sortir la
france de ses difficultés qu'elle lui je
vous rappelle mais je vous rappelle que
je suis le salaire je suis seul à le
dire ici mais vous êtes quand même au
courant vous avez passé 100% d'eads du
pin messieurs vous êtes quand même au
courant que c'est pas contre goody ça je
pense pas que vous serez responsable
mais vous venez de voter un budget avec
une prévision d'un fils de 84 2 84
milliards quand vous votez m budget de
pékin d'ici quatre ans comment
voulez-vous de façon promettre pour 2030
pour 2030 pour 2030
30 30 38 milliards ce sont mes poumons
et on est dans quel dans quelle diva
nommément la variable économique et
compresseur aux attaques armées
pour ceux qui nous écoutent sais que
c'est pas parce qu'il ya les 38
milliards sur ce projet de 18 qui encore
une fois est une colonne vertébrale qui
n'empêchera pas le maillage de tous les
projets de vous parler le contrat est un
région sur le développement d du rer c
des travaux sur le rer c le rer a le rer
b il continue il continue son chemin et
personne ne dit surtout pas que parce
qu'il ya la ligne 18 on va arrêter tous
les travaux de rénovation du réseau
ferré dont on a absolument besoin c'est
une évidence encore une fois on est sur
une à une
j'en veux dire une c'est pas les mêmes
budgets non c'est pas le même budget
c'est le contrat état région mais
celui-là il existe il est signé et en
place
il existe une action pas du tout
déconnecté il faut bien à l'argent c'est
l'argent des français toujours au bout
ça en est d'accord il faut bien
renverser j'aime bien remboursés ils
soient bien payer les intérêts nation
donc bien sûr mais l'engagement et
l'engagement de madame pécresse est pas
pour mais nous semble crédible et on à
la prévision budgétaire on a en a laissé
la reconnaissez même on vient
d'apprendre que on promet 300 milliards
pour le budget défense en 2025 puis de
cette année mais moi je vous ai
j'entends tout ça mais dans mes fruits
vous c'est pas votre bon prix mais on
sait plus comment vous derrière nous on
doit prendre des options sur le foncier
on à l'élysée les bébés les gens qui
bâtissent ces villes qui doivent
construire des projets loose mais ce
n'est pas tout parce qu'il faut quoi
mais je sais que tu travailles la fin de
la concertation parce qu'il ya eu une
concertation cda n'a jamais mais qu'a
démarré au mois de septembre avec
l'ensemble des élus
moi je retiens l'engagement du budget de
35 ou 38 milliards parce que comme vous
le dites j'irais saint quentin est puis
en cours au présent le bretonneux on
construit on construit pas des logements
y aura la guerre le rap à la gare donc
ça c'est entériné la gare de 50 est
installé là on peut construire on peut
lancer les terrains ça t'aurait y aura
une gare y en aura pas satoriz y aura
une gare à l'horizon 2030 donc on peut
lancer relancer les travaux du plateau
de saclay qui était complètement à
l'arrêt parce que est ce qu'il y aura
des transhumants pour le 65e vous allez
construire en dix ans en 2030 une gamme
et à nous à l'investisseur de l'ancien
projet irresponsable
est-ce que l'engagement des travaux qui
vont démarrer 2018 seront pas le gage
que la ligne basse faire effectivement
moi j'entends la responsabilité
évidemment là vous verrez si les budgets
sont engagés est engagée la croissance
très clairement le premier ministre dire
les budgets
donc les 35 à 38 millions seront engagés
dans la durée du quinquennat on verra ça
sans suite c'est le temps qui nous le
dira merci à vous d'avoir participé à ce
débat passionnant et ce à tous les
passionnés effectivement quant à vous je
vous donne rendez vous sur notre site
internet pour voir ou revoir cette
émission passer une agréable soirée à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]